would you rather be in a Battle Royale
with all your friends and family or be
forced to strangle 100 innocent kids
every day for the rest of your life how
would you even find 100 innocent kids I
love how they have to be innocent kids
the most evil kids Mike what's wrong
with you you also didn't balance this
mik this is so badly
balanced hello and welcome to another
episode of trash taste I'm your host for
today G joining me once again are the
boys and today we thought we'd have
another special fun episode what weing
today why are we having so much fun on
trash I don't know I we we've been
having a lot of fun recently but we're
going to be having even more fun because
we are going to be playing the classic
game of would you rather certified Hood
Classic this is probably the first time
I've played this game sober so this is
well luckily none of these are like pull
out all your nose hairs or take a drink
it's like pretty chill it's a nice it's
it's all hypotheticals now so we we
thought about doing this different way
so at the beginning we thought hey why
don't we just Google some of the most
commonly asked would you rather
questions and then we did that and then
we found some of the questions and we
were like this is this is boring this is
stuff we've already like discussed in
trash day stuff like would you rather
have flight or invisibility you know and
boring okay so we thought let's add a
little bit more spice and we got we
asked you guys over at our patreon to uh
give us some suggestions uh so we're
going to be taking I guess some of the
most your guys' suggestions so if these
are [__] takes it's your
[__] and if they are [__] we're going to
call out each username as well so you'll
never forget yeah we're also basically
revamping our patreon and offering a lot
more content uh you know we feel that we
weren't doing as much as we could do uh
but now we're going to be offering a lot
more stuff and a lot more exclusive
videos uh and asking you guys to get a
lot more involved in the videos that we
make so if you do want to help support
trash taste and everything we're doing
and or maybe just get involved in the
videos uh all the old perks are still
there we're just adding a ton of new
content uh new weekly uploads as well
that are exclusive uh there little fun
little short videos that don't really
fit on any of the channels but our our
fun video if you're a fan of trash taste
yeah so if you like to sport us go over
to patreon.com trashtaste Links in the
description but over at time over let's
let's get on to these would you rathers
we have 122 theoretically we could we
could get through2 yeah I mean some of
these are so easy like go to the first
one I know okay would you rather live in
the world of the MCU or Invincible okay
that's this is an easy one right wait it
is is it it is why would you want to
live in the world of invincible wait I
was going to say invincible why cuz it's
sick what do you wait bro you you are
you are literally like a [__] ant in
the Invincible world oh like I'm half
the [__] population died in the MCU
wellz [__] cuz a [__] Mr purple
[__] head came but they also did an
invincible as well yeah but nobody
suffers pain in the MCU right guys you
know yeah I po they just faint look look
look look you know I would rather just
fade from existence rather than getting
like my skull crushed or
[__] like imagine you're just on the
[__] train and like the Invincible
characters just start start a [__]
fight there you're going to die this
this is a [__] one because it's like in
reality you're just going to be like a
civilian in both of these universes
right it's not going to make a f it's
not going to make a difference you're
going to probably get caught up we're
going to get caught up in some like
[__] between like superheroes and
either way you're you're you're
helpless okay all right but then you
know because we have that one which you
know started a debate but the next
person asks all right would you rather
get into a car crash or eat a burger so
you know we have some really really
intelligent uh questions being asked
here and I honestly you know this is a
this is a comment on society as a whole
what do we value more a physical body or
what the ramifications are of I would be
sweating if I was a vegetarian if you
say yeah if you say eat a burger well
that means you support the meat industry
and the meat industry is very
problematic so I just want to it's
either you get hurt or the entire
Humanity gets hurt cuz you're eating
burgers and you won't stop well think
think of it this way who do you what do
you think kills more people per year
hamburgers is it crash or or or is it
everything that the burger industry
disease
Burgers Let's Just Ask America for a
second yeah car Crashers how do people
get into crashes on the way to get a
burger oh [__] you're on rest
my isn't it like cow burps like are the
biggest reason as to like or farts or BS
whichever one it was of why the ozone
layer is Getting Thinner or something no
no well okay okay M has to fact check
right
away it's something like that it plays
but it's not it's not like it's a lot
but it's not as much as uh me get the
particles and
[Music]
waves can travel through a vacuum
obviously right we've we've made it how
long in uh trash tase just before this
is going to be a speedrun of I mean I
wouldn't call it a trash T episode list
list it's bad it's bad but the point is
you would definitely want to get into a
no was right methane can react with
other gases to form water vapor which
then break down its other chemicals that
destroy the I wasn't arguing that it
didn't affect the Oz but you were saying
it like it's the most leading cause of
like pain to the ozone destruction cows
do definitely play it's a big percentage
I remember that it's a big percentage
what you would imagine it to be the oone
layer we're [__] chill with now it's
the [__] uh the other what's the
other [__] layer H [__] the ozone
layer we we we we basically fixed the
ozone layer there was a hole in the
ozone layer and we stopped using the
chemical so we basically were chill with
that we we can [__] it up still so we
try not to be [__] it up but it's the uh
other [__] layer the one with all the
greenhouse gases that are stuck point
being get in a [__] car crash no not
Stratosphere that's that's when you get
into space that's wait are you talking
about uh
the greenhouse effect that layer yeah
but yeah he literally just said that but
it's different the ozone layer is
separate I know I know the ozone layer
is different from that but the
greenhouse effect is not a layer
of we clearly know why are we talking
about this I don't know how we started
we're not
qualified we tried cling on something
Joe start throwing out facts we can't
see facts on trash I was saying the
correct fact and then you what's the
layer with the greenhouse no no you did
not say the correct fact move down fact
check him oh my God all right back to
the pat yeah the answer is eat a [__]
burger no we can't
crash I don't want to destroy the
environment Joey I don't want that on my
conscience I will never see you eating
another Burger again from this day
onwards you will never see it Mark my
you'll never see it it won't happen uh
just to spite uh I will just eat a
burger while driving my
car oh I'm going to [__] around and find
out get in the car in your last dying
moment just I'm going [__] around find
out and see what happens when I eat a
burger while I'm driving a car devil
Advocates today all right let's go next
one uh leave trash taste but you get 10
million I assume dollars and can't be
friends with the boys again or stay in
trash taste and keep making what you're
making bro $10 million I'm sorry boys
but [__] off what the [__] I going s
trash taste what the [__] [__] off boys
we still get paid we still hang out you
know I'm I'm going cry myself to my $10
million Villa Thank you very
yeah go how many G PS did I get you H
you you'll be back in a week guys the 10
all right
out I need more I'm back guys what the
[__] are you are you going to take me
back guys I don't know what would you do
10 mil right I take the 10 mil I make a
new
podcast I get I get another I get a I
get a not a tie that's too close I get a
Vietnamese friend and I get the 10 mil I
buy the rights to trash
I would sell you the right trash and
then get a Scottish guy and a Vietnamese
guy to co-host
with I I I'll get the 10 mil we get a
Bollywood
actor I'll get a Bollywood actor I'll
actually pay him to watch anime this
time yeah I love it if we're like so un
like we're not even friends and we have
to like we one of us is paying them to
be friends like no no no joy wouldn't
say that you didn't watch that
anime watch Conor would argue with me on
this you don't understand if I say this
food take you got to say [__] off God
cut cut redo this oh my God okay but
yeah we we take the terminal I would I
would I would I think I'd stay no no
realistically i' realistically patrons
they're helping us get eventually we'll
get definitely oh my Lord all right uh
Reverend Moore asks would you rather
have everyone you know be able to read
your thoughts or everyone you know to
have access to your internet history bro
this isn't easy are you kidding me why
the [__] would you want anyone to be
able to read your mind constantly right
yeah yeah that's what are you kid I
would argue for a lot of people that's
worse give me 10 bucks and I'll give you
my internet history I know man if if you
have nothing to hide then uh what are
you talking about what we all have those
intrusive thoughts I don't have any
intrusive thoughts I don't know what
you're talking about you literally said
you get in a car crash eat a what
you like we're driving right that'll be
so funny actually okay you know like
you're standing in line of MCD like I'd
rather be in a car crash like yeah we're
driving a car right and I I'm driving
and then you just think wonder what
Conor's thinking and you like Conor's
like I could crash the car right now
it's like the one intrusive thought I
have you're going to think what the [__]
I don't want people Snoop in my brain my
brain does [__] up stuff I didn't give
permission to do that by the way my
brain didn't I did not tell her to do
that honestly I think reading Minds is
one of the biggest monkey po kind of
like abilities you could ask for cuz
that would be that would mean you could
never have a
friendship or any kind of social
connection ever in your life at all um
because no matter how innocent they look
on the outside everyone has [__] up
thoughts yeah you know yeah you can't
avoid that right I I would like it would
be funny though if we could read each
other's mind and we' just be
like would we get to the point where we
couldn't tell if we were thinking
something or if someone actually was
saying something yeah like like we'd be
in a conversation I just look at gun and
I'd be like don't say what you're about
to say I'm like bro really really Joey
now now you're thinking that you'd
probably find a way to somehow suppress
your thoughts I feel like I can't do
that can you do that you do it out of
desperation okay here if you just keep
screaming I think I think I think the
idea
of I think the idea of suppressing your
thoughts is like something that makes
sense in your own head but in reality I
I don't think it's possible oh it is
possible it's called meditation uh I
said
medication well that that pretty helps
too
I mean it's it's very very like it's you
know as someone who's done meditation
before it's way harder to suppress your
thoughts then uh you kind of like
mentally think it would be there is
techniques that help you to do that yeah
like try to consciously stop thinking
yeah try it like try and stop thinking
for like a second well now that you said
that it's so hard but like meditation
isn't exactly like stopping thinking
it's just being aware of what you're
thinking uh it's it's like it's like
that whole idea of if I said like don't
think of a pink elephant you're thinking
of a pink elephant right now like it's
just it's are you reading my mind
think anyway yeah it's okay though we're
we're close enough friends that we can
already read each other's moment we'd
give away internet history any I think
this one is the easiest thing of all
time okay okay uh would you rather be
stuck on a desert island a deserted
island deserted island uh for the next 3
years or have to live in rural Ohio for
the rest of your life I mean I'll do
I'll do a year on the [__] Island
rural Ohio is just like a landlock
deserted is one year on the island I'll
do it like there's no way even if it was
3 years on a deserted island uh you
kidding me or 3 years in Ohio I'd still
think I'd do three years in a deserted
island yeah if it was three years on a
deserted island and one year in Ohio
I'll take the deserted island here's the
thing about deserted Islands though when
when we say deserted island people
always assume hey it's a tropical island
you know what if it's a deserted island
somewhere with shitty weather like in
the Arctic or in the Arctic or some [__]
like that died day one yeah I would
rather still live there though than
Ohio I can take the call it's just white
Ohio what can you get whiter than Ohio
no it's like like Ohio but you changed
the filter to
White not not white people that's what I
thought you were saying I thought you
were saying like no I don't think he
gets whiter than that all right this is
a threea uh one for each of us so for me
would you rather watch Arcane or join
the next chess boxing tournament chess
boxing tournament 100% what that's no
you've got to be that you you're meing
there's no way no I would you would
rather get beat up and train for a year
then watch a [__] 12 10 hour show
yeah there's no shot yeah cuz I get in
shape and i' get better in chest and
you'd have your you'd be you'd come back
like and I'd win some money if I want
you'd come back and you'd be like oh my
B don't work
concussion yeah so I'd rather go to
frontal La than watch Arcane uh for
would you rather eat only piz across for
a week for K and uh wait what for have
to dip everything you eat to dip
everything to dip everything you eat for
the next week into ketchup and Mir oh
that's good oh this this is actually
very very easy um yeah honestly I cannot
stand ketchup and mayor like just more
than pizza crust more than pizza crust I
could I I can me and pizza cross can uh
make peace for a second uh if I don't
have to dip ketchup and Mayo I you
remember what us talking about how our
taste buds change
like I think Pizza I think as I've grown
older I have come to hate ketchup even
more as I did as a kid I've every time I
seem to try it now it just seems to get
like the taste always gets more and more
sickening to me also it I think the
caveat here is it says you have to dip
everything you eat right and there's
probably a lot of things that are not
going to go well with ketchup anyway
like I unless you unless you selectively
choose foods that go well I look I can
pretend to be like you've been toties
with I can pretend to be
AAL every now and again if it's like if
I have like the social obligation to be
like okay this is the first time I'm
meeting people let's just try to fit in
for a second but in no way were can I
ever turn off that part of my brain that
says just dip it in the ketchup Mayo if
it's keepi Mayo maybe but ketchup I draw
the line of ketchup I just cannot stand
ketchup even spicy ketchup even spicy
ketchup
like really like mild
difference yeah and then for Conor would
you rather eat only oranges for a week
or have to sit through all of the Fate
La explanation videos for a week oh this
is a good one um for fate law
explanations like for a week what does
that mean does that mean like 24 hours a
day I'm sit there 24 hours 7 days a week
you have to have explanations like a
marathon yeah however long you would
take to get through all of the Fate law
explanation I guess which would probably
be a week straight being honest probably
fate law really really you hate oranges
that much [__] hate them they're
awful why would I want like a scrotum
texture thing that tastes of just water
and scrotum texture how did you find
point me to the last time you tasted a
scrotum how do you find a new thing to
hate about oranges every single week
they suck dude they just suck I just
don't like I at least I get to watch
something I like watching random
explainer videos about [__] I don't care
about so this is right at my alley
especially my week anyway someone tell
me about why I should care about like I
don't know cigarette companies likew is
interesting anyway SK oh you Skip One
yeah all right go for on okay so Derek
Wills asks let's start off uh let's
start things off fun would you rather it
hurt every time you pee or have it hurt
every time you poop so basically would
you rather have an STD or Gara basically
po wait does gor make your shits hurt
gor Yeah well yeah I've never had gor no
I don't know that I I don't know if
that's true either is it gor or is it no
hemorrhoids Hamid Hamid I was like G is
an STD Joey is an STD right sorry would
you so would you rather have
it I'm glad I I F checked it my bad
that's my bad on
that wait wait what is
gor now I'm confused right pull up
goria we're going to learn something
shout out to everyone who watches trash
taste while you are eating this this is
for you guys what is garia okay it's an
STD it's it is an STD okay um I just
know that oh so it's like a it's like a
ureth uh infection yeah so it's almost
like a UTI I guess which almost I guess
what is it caused by the garia bacterium
it says yeah fair enough okay so
rephrase yeah would you rather have an
STD where it to pee or would you rather
have
hemorrhoids I have not had either so
I've not had either but I I pee more
than I poop so actually can can I ask
what is hemorrhoids I know it's
hemorrhoids is well there's hemorrhoids
is when you basically have like a cut uh
in your like on your butthole yeah it's
inside though it can be inside or
outside really I thought it's inside no
I think there's two different kinds so
you can get inside
or don't bring up Google Images yeah
yeah yeah Mudan do not put any of these
images on screen right now thisor this
is just uh for us hemorrhoids is the
swelling and around
[Music]
Uranus that's a yeah so you can have it
internal or external it says about half
of people will have hemorroids by age 50
oh [__] [__] I mean maybe we have had
hemorrhoids we just don't know what I
don't know what hemorrhoids is I'm not
having h no you would I I'm pretty sure
you would have hemorrhoids why because
it's you can get it why would you say
like that because because you if you
spend too long [__] sitting for long
periods of time especially on the toilet
is a main call if you spend ages pushing
your bows like tensing and [__]
that's how you get it I don't spend ages
just tensing though you do yes you do
don't [__] lie you on the toilet for
like 10 hours I let it I let it like
[__] naturally go man there there's
no there's no I don't like I don't like
sit on the toilet and I'm like Goku
Going [__] Super Saiyan for 30
minutes straight Jesus Christ I'm just
relaxing you know it's gravity do the
work yeah yeah yeah you let gravity do
the work right we do a bet if you have
hemorrhoids by 50 450 you give me $100
you don't get
hemorroids I'll give you $100 wait what
do I get out of
this you mean so if you don't get
hemorrhoids you get $100 and you don't
get hemorrhoids soon bonus bonus points
if I get hemorrhoids yeah before ag50 I
give you
$1,000 have you guys ever had a I don't
know if this is like TMI have you guys
ever had a UTI uh no I haven't I haven't
no I I don't know how I I somehow got
one but I don't know if this is the
normal way to get one there was this one
time where I just held a pee for like a
really really long time like a really
really [__] long time uh because I
couldn't find a toilet cuz I was in
England uh and then suddenly everything
just burned it's UTI is just awful
sounds like it I like I've make sure to
pee don't hold in your pee just just I'm
saying this now this comes from
experience
uh don't hold in your PE because I
didn't know it could cause a UTI I just
thought you to deal with this recently
what's that you had to deal with this
recently oh yeah yeah yeah cuz Ari had a
a kidney infection and uh it's but for
her it didn't hurt to pee she just felt
like [__] yeah some sometimes yeah I
think sometimes it
depends sometimes it does sometimes it
do this is why whenever I get that
intense urge to pee I'm like I just got
to do it yeah I I can't stop I kind of
got like a mock feeling of it when I ate
that ghost pepper on the live stream and
then my pee turns spicy that [__] that
[__] hurt I was like ah is this what it
feels like yeah the worst thing about it
is that having it you constantly feel
like you have to pee yeah even though
even if you don't right what's the is it
just anti antibiotics is that how you
yeah antibiotics I hate that so boring
what you mean so boring medieval
treatment give me some blood letting or
something what you put the leeches on
the my
dick your dick already feels like it's
having like a with a leech on the end of
your suck it all out every time my dick
will get
sucked
I is this what felacio
is Medieval [__] be like well you
know you know when you you know the the
only time I ever test the you know my my
urge to pee and I fight it is when
you're in bed and you're sleeping and
you wake up and you're it's maybe like
midnight you're about to fall asleep and
you can feel the pee coming and you're
like it's not strong enough where I need
to pee but I know that there's a chance
I'll wake up in the middle of the night
or I'll wake up in the morning feeling
like it's also the worst when it's like
a cold winter night and it's really cold
outside the blank and you're like is
this cold worth it for me to get out of
the wall to go pee this will be on the
it'll be uploaded by then but I I on
Chris's uh Broad in Japan yeah Broad in
Japan is that what it is Noy Jaan that's
his channel name uh the first thing he
made me do I arrived in Sendai he's like
guys we're going camping and I was like
oh no no in the it's like the I was like
oh no oh no why why and um I was like I
I told him remember we we when we went
camping I and you and did you [__] up
did you [__] up with the the the
sleeping bag did you get to yeah yeah
yeah I got the Amazon one we all [__]
up with the sleeping bags right and I
told him I was like you got to get a
winter sleeping bag I don't want to go
through that again yeah I that genuinely
scared me yeah yeah I pring I I was
actually so scared cuz we went we went
camping in Fuji recap we went camping in
Fuji it went to Minus 5 and we had
Amazon basic sleeping bags which were
not
rated they were like summer sleep might
as well be a cardboard bag and uh I
didn't have any clothes I didn't have
anything and I was like you [__]
you I swear to God I kept telling him
cuz when I he he was like it's a secret
I can't tell you what we're doing and
then someone told me and I was like
we're going camping and I found out he's
really annoyed and I was like do you
have everything he's like yeah we have
an expert we have an expert I was like I
don't believe you do you have have you
confirmed we have winter sleeping bags
cuz this [__] is no [__] joke andai
it snows in the mountains especially and
and we were on a [__] Island a tiny
Island about the size of our office in
the middle of an ocean man Chris really
makes you do the [__] stuff I telling
him this I was like I have the best
experi I you bastard i' I have been on
this in my first one Joey has been on
like 19 of these and Joey only gets nice
cushy things they're all great why do I
have to be the one the [__] survival
situation so anyway we get there right
and he's like oh yeah we got to camp and
you know we this ton of stuff on this
boat we so much stuff yeah and I'm like
okay we have way too much stuff these
guys are prepared like crazy man this is
awesome and I'm set at my tent I'm
setting up Chris's tanks of course he
doesn't want to set up his own
tental there was a good time lapse yeah
that that Paul had it was really funny
May laugh Paul's like look at this it's
like Paul Chris on his phone watching
and you just see like me and Paul and
naty building the tents and Chris is
just on his phone watching it's very
funny I I don't I don't care I just find
it really funny
um but um anyway so I I get the sleeping
rag out and I look at it and I'm like
Chris it's only rated to like 2° yeah
it's going to get minus five tonight
again yeah that's this is this is no
nightm return this [__] sucks and I was
like I can't do this again I can't I
can't get me out of here like can I
leave like this is awful cuz I I knew
the [__] storm that was waiting me I've
already done it luckily this time I
brought uh some really good uh under
thermal stuff brought nice thi socks but
dude it didn't do anything thing again
it was [__] awful well because you're
also sleeping on the cold ground as well
yeah and we only had cuz last time we
had like a mat yeah we had a mat last
time we didn't have a mat this time we
had a very thin like uh reflective thing
so you're closer to the ground that's
why you lose most of your heat dude and
this is why I was why I bring out the
story because I managed to get warm but
what I had to do to get warm is is I had
to cuz you know the sleeping bag the
back of the head is larger right I had
to do this did you do this as well oh no
sorry I I was just like realizing before
we talked about this we're talking about
peeing so I was like are you going to
say you peed yourself W maybe so warm
myself up I was like I was like where's
this story going how does this so we I
had these we had these foot warmers but
we only had two each yeah and so I put
these foot warmers on my feet and said
it lasted 3 hours I was like great I can
get to sleep and then I'll be fine yeah
yeah and I was still so cold but my feet
were fine I had to get the back of the
sleeping bag I turned it over so it was
over my face yeah folded it over my head
made like a a cocoon
and I had to keep breathing into this
sleeping bag so I wouldn't lose the
moisture heat so I heat myself up so
cold again and I got to sleep [__]
finally uh breathing the same carbon
monoxide that I was breathing out and
then I woke up at 3 I don't think you
slept I think you just knocked
yourself I woke up at three with the
most strongest intense urge to pee in my
life yeah but I knew if I if I if I left
this sleeping bag it was game over like
I would never be able to get warm again
the entire night cu a pee coldness so I
tried to sleep it off for an hour I
tried to sleep couldn't sleep I had to
pee so I go out I go pee I'm like
[__] freezing I get back in my
sleeping bag I just cannot get warm so I
I can't sleep because it's just too cold
and I'm just there shivering like [__]
[__] Chris [__] Chris the whole time I
can hear Chris ripping plastic like
little plastic you know like scrunching
he's ripping out like the kaidos like
the heat charcoal AC one of those ones
yeah he was opening these packs for like
30 minutes I go on his tent in the
morning he had like 40 of them it was
insane uh it was the worst night I've
had in years uh [__] awful and that
was your first journey across Japan and
I'm never going back ever again I'm
never going back ever again [__] this
the point being that that that PGE was
so intense that I I was considering
pissing myself but I knew that it would
have made me colder ultimately so you
would rather have it hurt every time you
poop uh
P after all that point being uh yeah oh
we also they told us on the island if
you wanted to take a [__]
to clim up the hill take a [__] in the
ground a hole first and then P it in I
was like I'm I'm going to [__] myself
that's the Aussie way [__] doing it
but that was just a fun little story
yeah I mean [__] Chris by the way when
he comes on the show I'm maybe you
should pee yourself next time that's
that'll keep you warm like a good like
half an hour right yeah but then you
freeze and also you'd be trapping
yourself in the PE s
sleeping monoxide poisoning and now like
wet pants as well ended up getting up
waking up at like 6 being like [__]
this's going to make a fire front of
smell like an animal D so I just sat in
front of a fire for 4 hours until the
boat came to pick us up all right but
moving on to the next would you rather
uhhuh uh something dark as [__] would
you rather watch oh wow you want to read
out would you rather watch all your
friends and family die be forced to kill
100 strangers I'll kill the strangers I
kill the strangers oh are we doing like
in SE they'll respa this is literally
just the plot of Attack on Titan this is
this like the train problem except one
side is your friends and family and the
other side are a bunch of people but you
don't know and you're like okay well
yeah yeah yeah not even a question uh
next one is would you rather know the
definitive answer to what happens after
we die or know exactly how long you have
left to live that's good question I
think I'd rather have the definitive
answer of what happens after we die I
don't want either that's this is yeah
but you have to pick I have to pick one
if I had to pick I'd get the answer of
what happens after we die I think I'd
actually like to know how long I have
left to live really def do not if if
presuming it cannot change yeah so this
is like a [__] Death Note thing you
could see the vision see you're thinking
about this [__] I I I hear that and
it says 90 years old I'm like bring in
the [__] be let's get going I'm going
to live till 90 [__] see if if that was
the case with all of us then we would
pick that being like oh you have 57
years left live and You' be like sweet
but what if it's like you eat a
hamburger and the fck thing goes down to
like 20 like what if that hamburger
change or it's like or it's like uh you
have two minutes yeah like let me load
up the memes right now I got to watch
this de me before I die you watch you
watch that one porn category you're like
I don't know if I should watch this you
watch it and you immediately lose 10
you're like what what does this lead to
yeah what if what if just like you do
some like asinine activity and it's just
like why did my life go down by 12 years
yeah uh yeah I'd like to that would that
would kill me I don't really care what
happens to us when we die even if it's
good bad or nothing I'm kind of
indifferent towards all of it I don't
know I'm c i I want to know just because
it's like a new game plus anyway right
we start and do some [__] so it doesn't
[__]
matter I don't know I just I would just
like to know because it's like if even
if it's either good or bad it's like I
can't avoid it yeah so I'm just like
well I'd rather that than like living
with the pressure of like oh [__] I've
only got how many years thing ever and
then you're like well [__] it I'll die
now why wait and no no no worst if it's
the worst thing ever like hell right
you'd be like [__] I I don't want to die
and you'd be so scared of death yeah and
then and then I'd be like all right well
then I'm going to try and live for as
long as possible yeah well that's that's
why that's why I don't really want to
know either answer but I think the one
that would affect me less like what
happens after we die let's what's like
the worst case scenario we go to hell
and we suffer for eternity in your life
right um no it's not hell huh it's not
hell we haven't figured that [__] out
you think you think boo figured it out
and wrote it in a book for us [__] no
but okay what what do you think is the
worst possible thing nothing that's the
worst possible thing AB just infinite
Darkness forever no no no just like
you're gone that's it I think I think
people just don't want to accept that
we're just nothing when we're done no
that's I don't I don't think that's a
bad thing per se I I I [__] with
ITA I would rather stop existing than
suffer like iously suffer for the rest
of Eternity I think that you know like I
think when we are we are all specs on
this universe and we all get our moment
and we enjoy it and we're done and like
why should your conscience have to carry
on or why should you be a being gets to
carry on cuz I'm the main character gor
that's what we all want to think but
it's we're just done like that's it
you're done afterwards like there's
nothing wrong with that like you know
there's there's uh you you won't even
have the ability to know you're gone cuz
you're You're gone although if I were to
be Devil's Advocate right like if say
for example after you Di the answer is
you go to hell and you suffer for an
eternity let's say like let's say like
you know hypothetically speaking Yeah
hypothetically let's say like you know
[__] Satan puts you in a pool of
boiling hot water and you have to sit in
there for the rest of Eternity right you
have an eternity you're going to get
used to it yeah You' get used to it so
fast you'd get used to it' be like yeah
I guess like after like 5,000 years
you'd be like oh turn it up a it's a bit
cold you
know is this assing you can't die yeah
well because it's an eternity right you
can't die you're already dead right so
you're basically going to be boiling for
the rest of your life you're going to
get used to it after a while but it's
not exactly a pleasant experience is it
it's not pleasant at first that's what
you mean that first that's like a very
biblical way of looking at hell I think
that like hell could also be just being
stuck in Ohio for like four years that's
true that's true maybe I mean some
people are living that maybe FL we're in
hell right now we're living amongst
people who are also serving their time
in hell yeah what if existence is
hell what if what if what if this is the
suff think about that atheists
okay all fine all right let's go next
one all right something a bit Tamer uh
also from Derek Wells would you rather
have an unlimited entertainment budget
but be heavily restricted on your food
budget or have an unlimited food budget
but be heavily restricted on your
entertainment Bud entertainment is such
a that's such a broad word that that
could cover so many things Games movies
food is my entertainment as well it's
true yeah like oh [__] did you just play
did you just out play the game
entertainment entertainment could also
in some aspects could be like travel or
yeah you know staying you know so I
think if you we talking about travel now
well yeah travel is entertainment for a
lot of people okay let me let me
rephrase this question a little bit
would you [__] you we're change your I
guess if that is your real name yeah uh
would you rather eat like a broke
college student your entire life but
have all the games and travel that you
want you just described my
life that's me right now you don't eat
like a broke college student yes I do
[__] off Joey compar to you compar to
you [__] [__] off comp to you [__] how
often do you go to like fancy restaur
[__] cooks for you and you eat well
what are you talking
about that that is not a broke college
student
Joey before Aki and when AK is not here
I am [__] chomping on the worst [__]
imaginable what do you what do you hear
when ak's not there what do you like
[__] like gudon every single day
gon's great what are you talking about
excuse you gon is the col food in Japan
are you kidding me I love that visceral
call out go you go to [__] nice
restaurants all the
time you do I barely go to restaurants
you do go to you do go to the
restaurants I think the least out of all
of us yeah absolutely but you're also
cook at home or you have someone cook
you at home which there is there is
something really really [__] nice
about a homecooked meal you know home I
mean I'm not going to say no to a nice
restaurant obviously but I'm not going
to go out of my way to go to one you
know okay so what you're saying is you
would look this is not me saying I never
take AK to nice restaurant I
do you every no but that's the great
thing a a is exactly the same as me in
the sense that she also doesn't care
about
restaurants just like you she comes home
from like a hard day works like honey
don't worry I'll cook for us yeah like
brings out the [__] bring out the
Uber bring out the instant Ramen it's
just like okay honey here you go babe
it's a special day you can choose
between Mata or
sukia options I like who I like I like
yeah so like if I had to pick like I
would pick the first one the limited
entertainment budget cuz I love
traveling I love games I love movies all
that kind of stuff and food budget you
can in Japan especially you can still
eat pretty well with a restricted food
budget yeah uh you obviously struggle
when you're traveling of course but if
you don't include travel in the
entertainment budget hey I'm living yeah
worst comes the worse I will pick
unlimited entertainment over I mean food
to me is
very much you mean I I enjoy a good meal
it's something I look forward to every
day but that isn't so much dependent on
how much of a budget you have a lot of
times just depending on how much of an
effort can you put into learning how to
cook something you like and doing that
uh more often than not because you
finding a good place on a low budget
right ex obviously exists exactly so
it's a lot
easier uh pretty good for the limited
food budget really yeah I could have
some I just go out every single night to
a nice rest
restaurant you get bored of it you get
tired of you get bored of it I haven't
so
far all right Mr listen I go every I
just I go out every night no I mean I I
don't think I you never like crave a
homecooked meal
no no bro really no I never that's just
something like warming and homely about
I I like it but I've never thought man I
really want one right now this man's
been in La too much
one this is this is what Uber does to a
[__] I love Uber Eats it's so
good this what Uber does to a
[__] a restaurant meal and the
comfort of my home it's so
good all right restaurants yeah I love
love my parents to death but yeah like
restaurants are restaurants for a reason
no but okay there's something about a
homecooked meal that's listen if it was
your mom's homecooked meal I yeah maybe
there's a different equation here your
Mom it's my do your parents are your
parents good Cooks yeah they're okay
that was the most real
answer that was like uh what can I say
without them disowning me from my family
I mean they they they they swear to me
they're very good now which are sure
they are um but yeah all right listen I
had I had K's mom's home cooking and I
was like this pretty fire though that is
true it I think I think the answer makes
a big difference if you have at least
one parent who like British parents
British like this is a different
question you know what I mean I mean the
thing I loved about homecooked meals is
that okay you have like restaurant
quality meals you can go to like a melin
star restaurant but sometimes there are
certain dishes that you like the way
that you like it and with homecooked
meals you can just make it to exactly to
your taste profile exactly you know
sometimes you get a dish and like this
is 80% of how much I actually want of
this dish uh but like you know you're
satisfied with it but you're like damn I
wanted just that little bit more you
know there's a few places you can do
that I got a few place I go where
they'll customize if I ask I think
that's how restaurants get you as well
right like cuz like you have that
feeling of like damn I wish there was a
little bit more and then that just
incentivizes you to go back to that
restaurant again what do you mean like
is it it don't you think it's kind of
seems like a bit of a marketing scheme
to be like oh we going to give you just
a little bit less than what you actually
want so that you have that craving to
have it again I mean I think I just eat
more than the average person on a meal
right cuz I it it takes a little bit
more for like to fill me up than someone
like Sydney who is a a lot smaller than
me you know so it's you know it just
depends restaurant they have to serve
for the average person and most of the
times we eat more than the average
person above average person and you know
the way you uh you know the way a lot of
guys offset that is uh they get a
girlfriend or they get a wife and then
and then they eat just like 20% less and
they're like you're not going to finish
that honey yeah don't worry don't worry
say less say less I I'll do it for you
I'll do it for you all right you get two
meals for the price of one all right uh
what's the next
one would you rather gain a million
dollars but need to [__] out an entire
Year's worth of poop in a single day or
[__] one year worth of poop and never
have to [__] for the rest of that entire
year this is easy I would do the first
one gain a million dollar and [__] out
entire years worth of poop in a single
day why why they also say apologies for
poop topic but I want to see the Mone
why why well one of these I get to have
a million dollars and one of them I
don't dude it' be like dude if I made a
Tik Tok of that I'd make the [__] I'd
make an extra million although it would
be kind of useful never to need to [__]
again um I like [__] though I like
sh I kind of do like [__] though
yeah yeah it's yeah that's like saying
you know pee if it was peeing I think I
would like to not if it was peeing it'd
be a different peeing is actually just a
burden sometimes it is peeing
is the difference between peeing and
[__] yeah no one ever looks forward
to a piece sometimes I look forward to I
never look forward to a piece I always
look forward to my sh when I you know I
have a nice bit day I got I got a heated
seed I Got 5 10 minutes to chill out
it's great I feel yeah I feel like most
guys would answer the first one because
we just love out [__] an entire
Year's worth of poop in a single day I
don't think it' take that long D you'd
be like Randy from that one episode in
Family
Guy that's like how how long would that
take I did I say Family Guy I meant
South Park I don't think I have enough
hours in the day to put out all the [__]
and CU you you take an hour
yeah all right I think it would take
more than a single day for you to
[__] done two hours you've
done all right would you rather only
watch anime for your entire life or only
play games for your entire life yeah
games you don't even do that anyway
anymore Joey I I would rather play games
well you got this is this the only hard
thing for you yeah I like anime a lot it
going be wrong but games games easily
also you can spend more time on a single
game than you can on like an average
anime season you know so like you just
get more bang for your
B what if okay Joey what if we included
manga in that oh like cuz cuz I could go
without anime if I had manga but if I'm
just cutting out anime and manga that
makes it really really [__] hard for
me that's true uh because I do obviously
like I watch a lot of anime but also
enjoy playing my games as well and if I
didn't have to watch anime for a job it
I would rather I think it would actually
be a 50/50 about how much anime I watch
versus how much games I play yeah so
yeah it's hard CU I I probably read just
as much manga as I do play games yeah
but it says anime for this question so
I'm taking the games Joey taking the
easy way out taking the easy option also
I've already watched most anime so I
don't want to rewatch them yeah I think
oh this this is hard because I I I think
if I had to make the choice I do think I
get more emotionally attached to anime
but I think for like the amount of time
investment you put
in I got to go I can't like give up
games cuz you can also get the anime in
the
game what you mean jrpgs no there's like
there's some games where you can like
sort online game load videos or links in
like the
chat oh yeah you could watch anime in VR
chat play games in anime well I I mean
I'm going to assume that that's just
like a legal loophole that Roy clearly
didn't think about that there's cut
scenes you know yeah there's cut scenes
that that'll do me my other reason is
because just purely because as of like
my point in my life right now I have
played less games like in the broader
spectrum of the gaming world than I have
watched anime in the broader spectrum of
the anime world so there's more
excitement for me because there's more
Choice with gaming yeah it would it
would suck though if you made this
agreement and it's like every show
you're halfway through you've to stop
watching you can't finish you'd be like
[__] I wouldn't know how it ends that
would suck and no and like for some
reason no one else can tell you like you
never find out you never get to get that
Joy of finding out How It Ends true
maybe yeah maybe maybe that's a blessing
in disguise so because maybe I wouldn't
be [__] you Joy maybe I wouldn't be
spoiled on jiton for the h hundredth
time when I'm scrolling through my I
everything has been sped for me about
that show which kind of sucks
it's it's it's insane cuz I went like
four years I was like no Attack on Titan
spoilers and then suddenly I know the
entire plot of jiit kaon from now to
what's going on with the manga uh and I
get a different thing every single day
dude I could probably tell you just as
much about J K I haven't even [__]
watched this show I can tell you the
character ordered death to come don't
even know I can tell you how they die y
uh I I can tell you everything I can
write the wiki
bro I'm also I I I watched all of the
available episodes of freerun as of the
day of recording oh oh okay you like it
it's [__] good yeah it's really good
very [__] good not number one anime
of all
time solid show pretty damn it is very
very [__] good G yeah um all right
next one that's enough anime talk this
is the real question would you rather
spend a year in Ohio or a year in Paris
oh at least it would be Paris it's at
least a walkable City and I can get nice
coffee
also you're in Europe so you it's a lot
easier to access other countries
presumably you can't leave for a year oh
if you can't leave well I imagine you
have to spend the year there oh oh I see
I see uh yeah I'd say Paris Ohio what
can I do I can go to McDonald's I can go
to Wendy's I can go to a Chick-fil-A in
Paris I can go sounds pretty good
actually okay well Paris I get a nice
coffee I can get some good baked Quon uh
some other good stuff some good foods do
will I have to deal with angry French
person every day probably but hey I'll
manage yeah I mean this is this is Ohio
we're talking about Ohio is so
bad Ohio is the final boss not as bad as
like Montana well Montana's kind of all
right Montana is right yeah it's it's
all right it's oh it's it's oh yeah
there'd be very few places that could uh
like battle Ohio in the you know in the
final boss the It's the final boss uh so
yeah yeah we'd rather spend the year in
Paris I think I think Paris for all of
us this episode is sponsored by
expressvpn boys did you ever read the
fine print that appears when you start
incognito mode I'm illiterate there's
fine print on that it says that your
activity still might be visible to your
employers that's your school or your
internet service provider Ain't No Way
dog you listening Kai we can see
everything on your internet search
history now to really stop people from
seeing the sites you visits you need
expressvpn think about all those times
you've used Wi-Fi at a coffee shop a
hotel or even your parents house without
expressvpn every site you visit could be
logged by the Admin of that Network and
that's still true even when you're in
incognito mode I mean do you really want
your parents to see what you've been
looking at Jay no they would disown me
what's more your home internet provider
can also see and record your browsing
data and in the US they're legally
allowed to sell that data to advertisers
thank God we have expressvpn because
expressvpn is an app that encrypts all
of your network data and reroutes it
through a network of secure servers so
your private online activity stays just
that private expressvpn works on all of
your devices and is super easy to use
the app literally has one button you tap
it to connect and your browsing activity
is secure from those prying eyes yes I
was just joking cuz all trash taste PCS
are equipped with
expressvpn staff members you are safe
stop letting strangers invade your
online privacy protect yourself at
expressvpn.com Taste use our Link at
expressvpn.com traste to get 3 months
extra for free that's ex p svpn
/ras to learn more back to the episode
so the maniton asks would you rather
give the first 90% of [__] of a
[__] or give the last 10% of a blow
job asking three JoJo fans here that's
uh that's a really good one because oh
man cuz you have to now presumably you
get nut in your mouth yeah you have to
debate with yourself do you want nut in
your mouth or do you want to endure the
large majority but no nut your mouth
yeah so it's it's all about the nuts
it's it's the nut question basically do
you want do you want to take the nut or
do you want to put in the effort suck a
dick and I'll do the last 10% you know I
think I'll do the last I feel like I you
know I'm the one who did it I did the
job I did it you know it's all me all I
had all the credit for the
work why not why not yeah also you know
depending on the dude it'll take like 2
seconds or it could take like I or if
it's Johnny SS you'll be there for 40
minutes yeah you could be there for 40
minutes you get like [__] jaw
problems you know if it was me it'd be
like 2 seconds what a [__] dumbass
question a stupid ass question well some
people don't want none their mouth man
oh my you it is why is this a question
so
bad all right going on to the next one
let's
see uh go back to daily uploads or
stream every single day I mean streaming
every I I feel like this is the same
question but if it was if this was me
I'd rather stream every day yeah
because I think daily uploads like
streaming is basically just doing daily
uploads just without the uh just without
the chat interaction basically also you
can make more content out of like a full
days of stream than you can of like a
full day of making daily uploads I feel
so yeah but you need to stream every day
so actually actually if you if you do
daily uploads you can get away with one
stream like seven ideas worth and then
you've got your daily uploads right yeah
or like having like one having one
recording session yeah where you you
just oh [__] you're
right I think they they're kind of the
same thing really if you think about it
it's just whether or not you want to
stream or not yeah uh I I actually think
i' i' do daily uploads yeah I think
daily upload I I do daily uploads you
good batch that's true could record A
month's worth that's true yeah all right
Mason lasagna asks would you rather be
only able to [__] in one minute Max or
have to [__] for at least 30 minutes so
nowhere in between
how would the mechanics be of this like
like you're you're one minute in and
your pants like robotically just back up
I mean yeah you yeah probably I you [__]
yourself I think you just described the
two different types of [__] that are
sitting on this table basically you
basically described are you a woman or
are you a
man I don't know about you dude my
sister shits in like 30 seconds it's
actually insane I I [__] in 1 minute I
[__] in 30 minutes yeah no no yeah I
thought that was more normal like taking
like 30 minutes for a dud no what I what
I do is is I get there I take the [__]
it takes like 30 seconds and then I sit
there for 10 minutes cuz I just want to
sit down really yeah what about you what
aspect of this is taking 30 [__]
minutes ask the D takes 30 minutes just
chilling out okay are you are you like a
toothpaste roll are you like you you
crimping the
inside to get explain this before but
you know like when you go take a [__]
right when you go take a [__] you sit
down and then it's just like that
immediate relief that you get like a
good like 70% out and you could walk
away I know what you're talking about
you could walk away you could walk away
psychotic what you mean it looks
psychotic look he only brings 100% of
the effort to the toilet this is why
you're going to get hemorrhoids before
the age 50 g because you're trying to
squeeze out the last 30 which isn't
coming out it's not ready yeah I thought
you said you'd let gravity do it work if
it was ready because it takes 30 minutes
yeah it does no but if you're straining
that's not gravity doing its work that's
you forcing it out no no no it's it's
like you get 70% out and then you could
feel there's a bit more there's a little
bit more yeah I Reser I reserve that for
my afternoon [__] kind to come back
later if you that's like pre-ordering if
you just keep sitting it's just you
you'll get it out no you're forcing it
out that's why are you forcing it out
literally how you get hemorrhoids you're
going to get hemorrhoid cuz you're
[__] forcing it out you know what let
just I you know fine I'm going to get
hemorrhoids then when when when I get my
100 Buck the moment you get the
diagnosis you got to give me hundred a
clean 100 you get a double Bill one from
cor one from the I know the exact
sensation you're talking about because
I've been on the toilet where I've had
the same feeling and I'm like I think it
will come out if I sit here and just try
and get it out for 30 minutes and it's
just it's better to just walk away just
say no it doesn't I can't just be
completely empty no I'm going to come
back when it wants to come out look I
don't really care what doctors say this
is like when doctors say oh oh don't
don't use that's a good I don't care
what doctors say I don't care what
Doctor it's like when doctors say oh
don't use cotton BS to clean your ears
we like we a lot of us are still going
to do it let's be honest guys I do it I
listen to the doctors huh I listen to
the doctors when it suits my agenda
exactly exactly you know what if doctors
say Do not sit down for the rest of the
30% [__] that you can tell is still in
there after you take a [__] I'm going to
be like but I'm going to do a gamer move
anyway I'm I'm going to sit down Dad we
got to get a poop expert on the podcast
that's what we need and honestly why
would you want toist why would you want
to deprive yourself of like just a nice
relaxing [__] I don't understand why in
the middle of [__] recording G gone
for 30 I got [__] to do come on we we
we're waiting on you and you're here
like dangling it out go I get it
out no no sometimes sometimes I just
it's just hard for me to focus so you
don't want to [__] in one minute you
want to take 30 minutes I think if I had
to I'd rather take 30 minutes that's
[__] that's preposterous I mean like
I'm think that's such a long time cuz
I'm thinking about it now I'm thinking
about it now and it's like on average
how long do I take that make like a cur
video about your guys' lifespan I'll be
like you spend 50 million hours sleeping
and then 2% of your life [__] hey it
work actual actually okay here's the
thing would you rather only be able to
sleep for one hour or have to sleep 8
hours every single day without this
taking into account that you'll be fine
even after 1 hour sleep yeah why the
[__] would I want to sleep one hour is
as in like you're saying that like I
have the option like you'll be fully
rested even after an hour yeah you can
100% totally and I and I and I don't get
the normal 16 hour like tired cycle so I
would get would I what time would I get
tired would it be like 1 hour before I
go to bed or would I get tired like
hours before let's say let's say every
night it happens between 1: and 2 a.m.
so so I'm sleeping between like 2 and
3:00 a.m. but I get tired around warm
yeah yeah dude then but then by 5:00
a.m. you're fully awake and fully are
you kidding me yeah [__] yeah hell yeah
it's not even a question the amount of
the the amount of time you have is
insane because think about it this way G
right like okay you say like You' just
added 25% of active time to your life
cuz think about it this way right like
you okay they like you sleep for 8 hours
right sure you get the full8 hours but
in your head it doesn't feel like 8
hours does it does it yes it does no it
doesn't yes it does because when you're
asleep you have no conception of time
because you're asleep yeah but okay when
you wake up you judge it by waking up
yeah you judge it by waking up but still
sometimes you know when you've just okay
sometimes you oversleep you know when
you over sleep right totally you you you
to your body tells you hey you just
slept a [__] time and you [__] and you
know that every time I don't know to me
I I I look at sleep the same way I look
at [__] you know is it always the
most efficient use of time no obviously
if I could like if if I could cut out
all [__] in my life I would give
myself x amount of more time in a day
you know but do I enjoy the fact that I
can good look forward to like a good
nice rested sleep um for like but you
can get that within an hour the hour
gives you that same sensation also let
me let me propose this G if you could if
you only had to sleep for an hour and
you'd be fully rested that's more time
for you to take a sh I'm literally just
offering you more time there's no down
I'm just saying hey you can just have
straight up more time in your life
you're like no I don't want
that yeah I mean I'd rather I'd rather
spend that extra time that I have to be
fully unconscious it's like I'm saying
do you want 7 hours a day extra to do
[__] and you're like no do we need 7
hours a day to do extra [__] my god do
we need do we need 7 hours a day we
would be flying cars if that was
happening right now would be watching
all the [__] I that is on my backlog
yeah I'd actually be watching anime I
feel like that's a
lie Joey Joey that's that's an absolute
lie that's an i' be playing games that
is an absolute lie yeah I don't know I
mean more time is great I guess there no
in in The Logical sense would I be
happier with more time I don't know I
don't know if I would be happier with
more time but I mean like sure but like
you would be able to I mean what you do
with that extra time is up to you right
I think so like I think just even having
that option is better off especially for
people in our position where we have to
be you know on our own time schedules
and be as productive as we can with the
limited amount of time we have think
about think of how much [__] we can make
if you just had an extra even 5 hours in
a day we just become even more
workaholic
and I don't know if that's a good thing
or a bad thing you can spend that extra
7 hours watching anime playing games
doing whatever the [__] you break yeah
whatever the [__] you want it doesn't
matter you know you can you can use that
time however
much I feel like when you have an
abundance of something is when you
stopped appreciating what you have you
know that's that like why aren't you
like that with [__] then sorry why
aren't you like that with [__] I I
do appreciate that what are you talking
about Joey I appreciate the time I have
with [__] AB
that's for sure you're saying that 23
hours a day is too much time for you I I
think it would be I don't know 23 hours
a day that's a lot of time right and yes
I could be a more productive member of
society and all that kind of [__] would
do I think I would be happier with 23
hours of time in the day I don't know if
I would be because I would I mean right
now I'm like every let's say like you
know all three of us every spare moment
we have we fill that [__] up with uh
just doing more work right
we know we we we say to ourselves hey we
uh we would like to watch more anime we
would like to play more games but you
know I've you've had like a holiday
where you have like a week off and then
you just do nothing but become a
degenerate and play games watch anime
then you're like [__] I feel like [__]
because I didn't do anything but play
games and a watch anime for seven days
straight and then you're like yeah but
that's because you're playing it for
seven days straight like if you had that
extra 7 hours in the day like you would
after a while once you actually got your
body and mind into into that Rhythm
you'd be able to start you know uh like
you know putting you know a certain
schedule together of like okay yeah sure
I have that extra 7 hours but I can
maybe split it up with like maybe 3
hours of that is working and then 4
hours of it is doing whatever the [__] I
want right I feel yeah we could do that
anyway Joey we like people do do thatway
have more time think of how many jrpgs
you could finish Joey here's the thing
Joey you finish Final Fantasy in a day
Joey crazy here's the thing Joey I do
not believe for a second that if you had
more time that you do all the things
that you think you're going to do have
you ever had that moment where okay
you're in like you're you're in exam
like you're in exam period or something
right or you're in like a period where
you're in crunch time in work sure and
then all you can think about is holy
[__] if I had more time I can't wait for
this project to end cuz once this
project ends then I'm going to have time
to do X Y and Z and all you can think
about is fantasizing about having this
project in or having exams end right and
then exams end and you have all the time
in the world and you're like the [__] do
I do what do I do now what do I what do
I do now speaking for yourself gone
after exams I went hard you have like a
day or two where you're like [__] this
this is great and I immediately was like
I can't wait to play 10 hours of games
yeah totally I and then I played 10
hours of games and then two hour like
like two days in I was like [__] I don't
know what to do with my time anymore
this is I did not feel that way I I
think I played it for like seven months
straight dude think think of the amount
of like new hobbies you can pick up just
even in that time like you could do
whatever the [__] you want in that time
yeah but with new hobbies you'd have to
like go with the Circadian rhythm of the
rest of the world anyway you know you
you aren't changing you don't have to
not necessarily what if your new hobby
is like building gun PL you can do that
at 3 in the [__] you know you can do
that 3 in the [__] morning learned
that we live in a global world and there
always day somewhere there's always
going to be some hang out with or do
stuff anytime you are awake someone is
awake on disc I also have teleportation
ability in this universe to
yeah it's really cool the only downside
to only getting only needing one hour of
sleep is that a long flight would be a
[__]
chore cuz you wouldn't be able to sleep
through it cuz you'd only need an hour
and then if you're on a 12-hour flight
you'd just be awake for 11 hours doing
what watching
anime [__]
that that's what I do Joey I just like
to me flight's just like oh it's my uh
anime Marathon the same Jason Stan movie
five times in a row yes the one and
two but yeah to me I feel like I
definitely like my rest time you know
and it's it's something I cherish and
it's something that I feel like I don't
know if I would want to get rid of even
if I had the opportunity to get rid of
uh but yeah that's just me Gus 108 says
would you rather become an anime review
Channel or stop watching anime well Joey
actually got offered this exact
conundrum in real life and took one of
the options yeah I picked the correct
one I would like to
think did you just read that
just you bastard all right here here we
go here's here's here's a fun one would
you rather watch only 5.0 and lower
rated IMDb movies or only watch 5.0 and
lower rated anime based on my anime list
movies movies cuz movies that are like
dog [__] are funny and anime that are
really bad or under five are generally
not funny also uh it's like anime series
right that are five that's longer than
an average movie so you'd be able to get
through true but the movie is faster I
feel like you know let's let's take like
you know IMDb movies versus my anime
list this is this is talking about
entertainment [__] right yeah what what
Conor just one of the [__] questions
he's a psychopath would he write that oh
the Demi one no no below that
oh what kind of who comes up with that
Mick Mike are you good bro sorry g g was
explaining and all I could focus on was
that Mike said would you rather be in a
Battle Royale with all your friends and
family or be forced to strangle 100
innocent kids every day for the rest of
your life how would you even find a 100
innocent kids I love how they have to be
innocent kids there most to evil kids
and you'd have to do that every day why
100 you run out of kids 100 kids that's
it Mike what's wrong with you you also
didn't balance this mik this is so badly
balanced Mike you're a
psychopath sorry you're saying you I
could now you just like [__] hack out
of [__] pocket hung string I think
Mike is Mike is like he probably thought
like 50 no I'd do 50 that'd be too easy
I'll do 100 that okay but to go back to
the the 5.0 one right like we'll get to
that
want to that one I've seen a lot of
anime you want to answer that one yeah I
want to answer that one I thought we
were I've seen a lot of anime that are
5.0 and below and I've seen a lot of
movies that are 5.0 and below and on
average of my experience I had a better
time watching the lower rate of movies
too like a bad movie is kind of fun cuz
you know it's going to be over in 40
minutes by the time you realize it's so
bad like with with 5.0 and lower anime a
lot of them are just like so mid that
it's not even worth committing like
they're not even the so bad that it's
good it's also so painful like watching
a physical actor be like in a scene that
is just bad is so much more funny
because it's almost relatable like you
can you can relate to the fact that this
is probably awkward and [__] for the
actor as well the anime the anime
equivalent to that is just aggravating
to watch yeah cuz someone had to animate
it it's like someone [__] up either
like the music [__] up the voice
acting's bad the animation is horrible
like it's it's it's not fun to watch
it's just sad like whereas watching
someone be bad at acting is kind of like
this weird cathis where you're like man
I can kind of relate and I sympathize
which makes it equally funny that they
were cool this out I I feel like I've
seen more badly rated movies that I
actually enjoy than badly rated anime
that I actually enjoy it's it's it's
funny because if I see a 5.0 in an anime
rating I'm like this [__] is dog [__]
yeah I think the worst rating you could
possibly have is five I ever seen
anything yeah if if you're if an anime
is actually like technically mid like
the actual death technical definition of
the word mid it's terrible the only
thing worse than a bad anime is a
forgetta mid anime which a lot of 5.0
and lower up yeah and it's weird
sometimes I've seen 5.0 or like kind of
like that kind of like rating scale of
movies and some of them have just really
interesting ideas that are just executed
really badly whereas if it's it's a 5.0
anime it's probably going to be generic
harm or generic uh isai isekai I shut
the [__]
up that's why you seen so many why you
got why you got why you got your army
yeah that's the thing right so it's like
I would much rather just see like a
really like terrible movie that is just
so terrible that it's funny yeah rather
than just watching a bunch of shows I'm
going to forget immediately after I
finished watching it yeah so i' take the
movies any all right yeah I take the
movie as well all right let's answer the
[__] psychic one then all right the
out of pocket we've won so far would you
rather be in a Battle Royale with all
your friends and family will we forced
to strangle a 100 innocent innocent kids
every day for the rest of your life what
is your opinion that won't possibly get
you on a watch
list well Joey them kids
[Music]
man so why are you killing
potentially again this is just the uh
Ain question right yeah this you you
this to Aon Jager
both both why not both actually why not
80% of all of them what if you what if
it's a battle royale with all your
friends and family or just a battle
royale with 100 innocent kids would that
make it better it's not even a battle
royale but it' be a
massacre what are those kids going to do
I just back I just wanted to answer this
question cuz the Battle Royale with your
friends and family I think would be
pretty epic you know it'd be an epic way
to go I don't think I'd win you know but
I mean I I mean I would argue a lot of
uh especially Asian families do this
with family
Wheels that's so true so it's already
happening yo grandma dies like load up
the [__] fortnite
music where we dropping grandma
Yeah holy [__] you have the [__] long
lost Uncle you haven't seen in 20 years
the map and you're like [__] he was much
what the [__] did you sport in oh godamn
all right move to a different country
every year or live in America for the
rest of your life oh that's a doozy cuz
moving
sucks s is
America uh but I well you have 193
countries to choose from right so you're
not going to cover every single country
in your life you get so good at just
living in places for kind of short
periods of time yeah it be better if it
was like one month cuz then I could just
get used to not being in the same place
all the time what if you could just like
instead of having to go through the
process of moving let's say you could
just like spawn and have your place like
have have a different to easy have a
different place no then I definitely
choose
that is there hundred and like is there
okay how many how many years do we have
left that's 60 for being assume 60 okay
being really generous are there 60
different places countries in the world
that you think you'd be happy living in
yeah I'm down to try i' say yeah I'm
down to try you gives me enough time to
either I absolutely [__] hate it or I
like it it gives me enough time to
figure it
out but uh Living in America for the
rest of my life you basically say I I'll
know in a
week I could do America though I think I
could do it I can make work it depends
where I'm basically American it depends
where you are basically your okay what
if let's change the question a bit okay
what if it's moved to a different
country every year uh like or live in a
different state every month for the rest
of your life well [__] no I'm not going
to choose that that's that's psychotic
I'm going to pick I I actually think I'd
pick Living in America for the rest of
my life over moving a different country
at a certain point there are different
stop moving yeah at a certain point
there you know it would just be can't
have kids yeah can't really have kids or
the kids would be really unhappy can't
have pets really because you're moving
all the time you know you know you know
a feeling where you just have a house
and you're like [__] I can buy the
furniture now and know that this is the
furniture that I want that is going to
remain uh instead of just having Airbnb
Furniture you know it's there's there's
so many like micro things that you take
for granted about just having a physical
place that you know you're going to be
in for x amount of years in your life
you know and taking that away I mean
it's obviously exciting to move to a new
place but only you like you you do that
enough times and it just kind of gets
stressful knowing that you can't plant
your roots now that you can't plant your
roots somewhere yeah I mean I there
would def be enough countries in the
world I think where I'd be pretty happy
living in for the rest of my life but
yeah that now that you said the whole
moving process that does sound like a
pain in the ass
yeah all right right Americans you get
the W this time [__] sake coconut
coconut asks would you rather try to
cuddle with a polar bear or kill and eat
a penguin with your Bear Hands question
is this uh one of them is you die or you
get
food yeah I'm I'm sorry penguin you're
You're gone why the [__] would I try and
I die yeah this should just be would you
rather kill an either penguin or kill
yourself I'd rather kill and eat a
penguin actually well I've I've listened
to enough Joe Rogan podcasts to know to
know guys Jonathan here eating a penguin
giv you Jonathan is a really good one
actually right all right what what is it
would you rather lose your taste buds or
lose all of your memories from the past
five years of your life
oo both would be horrible both would be
horrible especially for us cuz the past
5 years have been pretty nice for the
most part for me I would choose lose my
taste
parts I don't know
actually I would choose lose my memories
for the past 5 years I can ask people
what what I did I can I just oh [__] I
just realized my wedding was in the past
five
years here thing all of trash tastes in
the past five years caveat right to make
it more fair cuz I think losing your
taste B is huge deal and I think you
know five years that we can probably
think of some ways to make it easy yeah
yeah nobody knows you've taken this deal
not even you if you take the deal to
lose your memories Al so you're not even
aware you've lost your memories you've
lost your memories but you don't
understand why you've lost them right
okay which would make this probably more
traumatic but um yeah you just made it
the deal worse yeah yeah but I'm just
trying to say I think actually the
memories is kind of stacked right now I
think the memories is too strong yeah
see I think my my logical reasoning of
why I would choose I would rather lose
my taste buds is because yes you lose
your sense of taste but you still have
your sense of smell which is kind of
like taste [__] Jo no this is why go to
restaurants by the way [__] He's
smelling on the outside even if you
can't taste the food you can still smell
the food so it's kind of like tasting it
no Joey yeah like cuz like you know that
experiment of like how they like make
you smell one food and then they make
you eat something that's completely
different and it completely changes the
way of how you taste that food
like it's called an all factory system
for a reason it's all connected there's
still taste being is a part no that's
what yeah but like what I'm saying is
losing your taste buds and only your
taste buds doesn't necessarily get rid
of taste in general it's there but just
in space Joey just goes to a restaurant
has one whiff and he's like I'm
satisfied I've eaten take it back take
it back oh oh so full I couldn't the
[__] I couldn't smell another bite I
couldn't I possibly couldn't but if you
lose all your memories in the past 5
years then that's just like there's no
backup just having an all you eat Buff
when he goes to the gas station he's
like I'm full I could I could smell
another drop yeah I'm good I'm I'm I'm
fulled up I think I would go for the
Memories really yeah no I think that
would just be sad because like okay say
for example even if someone was there to
like my sh on camera yeah but even but
like it's say you want YouTubers making
a hoton all right I don't have any
[__] pictures as well what do I what
do I have gone I got have something you
have the friends you have the friends
that you had and that will carry because
I feel like hearing those memories again
would be really sad because like a lot
of those memories would be fun but then
you'd get that sense of sadness of like
well it sucks cuz I don't remember
experiencing it you got live you got to
live without your taste buds okay okay
okay actually actually let me choose
losing my memories cuz I can watch
Attack when Titan for the first time all
over again baby yeah I I honestly think
about how many anime you can watch it
you can watch Arcane again for the first
time that actually was a good point God
you underestimate how little shows I've
watched in the past 5 years there isn't
a lot to rewatch my entire life in Japan
I wouldn't remember yeah your entire
life in Japan you would not remember
think about how and then how confused
would you be when you suddenly wake up
and you're like where the [__] am I I
guess I would know zero Japanese as well
yeah all the friends you made here gone
I'm memor it's not like it's not it's
it's only the memories that are going
the friends are still going to be there
Japan's going to still be here you can
make new memories it's okay it's it's
like this does [__] it does suck but
like with your taste buds you live with
that [__] for the rest of your life I
don't think I would want to live on this
Earth if I couldn't eat nice food but
you can you can still smell
it I'm telling you you can still [__]
smell the
food and that's a big part of your like
eating food experience is smelling the
like eating something while you've had
like a stuffed nose is completely
different to just being normal oh it it
it's still completely different but it's
still it's better that I can taste like
a little bit of it without taste buds
you remove one of the
little happiness you get every day
[__] gigantic okay well gigantic
whatever you know tasting that coffee in
the
morning would you rather have no arms or
no legs [__]
uh oh uh no legs no legs let's go why
cuz you can't game or you I can't
jack oh my God we are a bunch of monkeys
I feel that like you know there are a
lot of it is easier to uh I don't know I
feel like the things that I really value
in life I do with my arms uh and
obviously getting around
uh you know yeah playing games all the
stuff you know I can do without arms but
I think I just would like to be able to
also prosthetic legs are a thing protic
legs are [__] sick you know and like
we have like you know like arms are
getting better we yeah we have like you
know the technology of like robotic or
like automated arms or whatever like for
people who don't have an arm is getting
better but areu but the legs are like
they're Next Level now you know well
that's presumably depends what type you
have cuz some people can't have those
yeah oh really yeah it's not not every
not every it doesn't work like one
everything you know it's fine I'm
chilling I think I I like I'm down cuz
there's more you can do with your hands
than with your feet I would I would get
jacked with my arms as well I'd be like
Joe Swanson family
gu i' be
huge all right uh wait was there another
I think there's one good one was that
right what was the uh which one would
you rather fight 10 parents at the same
time 10 100 children what's with the
fighting children you're kid some wild
[__] would you rather have Sydney's
headtype references or Joey's headtype
references well boys I don't know if I
ever saying this I don't want to either
I'll be real with you I mean I would
rather my own well obviously obviously
but what do you guys think what's what
what is your like textbooks example of
your preferences well I know Sydney's
textbook preferences and it's a lot of
like I want Sydney really it's [__] I
don't even touch I mean I know Syd's
anti preferences I think i' go for yours
just out of like I have no choice but
like what what is yours what would you
like I'm just saying that cuz I don't
even want sydneys I just
[__] anyone's but Sydney wins by
default cuz it doesn't have NTR and ugly
balls and gr like any of those [__] up
syney likes really [__] up you'd have
to play if you had Sydney's H prefences
you would have to play some of the most
like abominable like error I I feel
ashamed whenever I even like see those
and I'm like man it's sad that my other
Bros out there are watching
this someone's watching this someone's
getting off to like ugly Bastion
although if you had my hentai
preferences uh you would have to watch
every single hentai that ever comes out
whether it's good or bad what does that
mean why cuz that's what I do I I give
everything a go and like see if it's
good or bad what's your preference
that's not preference my preference is I
watch everything okay all right okay so
you'd have to sit through probably a lot
of [__] you don't like I I just click it
and I see if it says any categories I
don't [__] with I just don't watch it
which is 90% of hent nowadays well which
I think is what that you just described
a
preference that's the same for me or
that's just a taste yeah one of them is
literally would you rather be aist or
[Laughter]
Kyo that's so funny Would You Rather
become the MC of red over a Healer and
do what he did or become the Black
Swordsman AKA K this guy literally
thinks he's like
man I know I know the always hate C but
how is how is sord on online got such a
bad rap where people think this is like
a legit question it's just an easy
punching bag isn't you get you get like
intense trauma your entire life then
become a hideous horrible human being or
become a protagonist of sort online or
just have a nice cushy Life playing
video games get married and uh have have
girls for over you I I know I don't know
man I don't [__] with Kyo normally but
I'm definitely [__] with him in this
instance would you rather be right or be
happy well I can tell you for one thing
guys trash taste is one of them I feel
and it's not right I feel like a lot of
people would say happy but I think a lot
of people secretly would rather be
miserable and be right all the time well
it depends who you're asking right if
you're being British isn't it uh Yes
actually I think actually I would rather
be right all the time what are you I
[__] knew you what you read
it and because it would get to the point
where I'm always right and then everyone
would [__] be like dude he's always
right he's [__] [__] sucks to be yeah
then you wouldn't be happy yeah but you
wouldn't be happy it would just be
miserable I think I would get happiness
eventually from being right all the time
but here's here's here's the question I
always like struggle with would you
rather be ignorant unhappy or
knowledgeable and miserable you know
because ignorant and happy ignorant and
happy because I I like I I get this I I
get this sometimes whenever there's no
punishment for being ignorant
you know what I mean like you just you
don't know you're ignorant you're just
happy that's all you know I think I'd
rather be ignorant happy yeah the smart
person but like I I think I think at
some point we made the conscious choice
to stop being ignorant and yeah but
there is the saying ignorance is bliss
getting getting like learning and
getting knowledge and expanding is is
addictive but also
dangerous yeah because okay you know
there's a moment in our childhood I
guess where we were [__] ignorant but
you know we were happy about that a lot
of the times and I feel like
as an adult I have happiness were we
ignorant or were we just unknowledgeable
cuz I think there's a difference well
we're just [__] idiots cuz we're kids
yeah we kids well ignorant that's the
same thing right no ignorant means no
what what is the definition of ignorant
ignorant is like you're doing it right
now well no not being ignorant because I
want to know so I know I'm wrong
ignorant is like you are completely like
to lack a large amount of awareness on a
subject disc lacking knowledge awareness
in general uneducated or unsophisticated
unsophisticated God damn God damn Google
you didn't have to go in that
hard you don't think about maybe like
what else there is out there maybe
you're content with like your very like
like you know like Clos minded not not
close minded that's like conscious
ignorance you know if if you consciously
block off the rest of the world then
you're consciously choosing to be
ignorant right but there is there is a
point where we made the guess I guess
like the conscious decision to go
outside our bounds to go outside of
let's say our little town or our bubble
our world and we chose to become more
knowledgeable about the world um did it
make me happier I don't know if it did
honestly sometimes I see a lot of people
in like the small towns that we came
from and I'm like damn they're just
[__] happy man they're they're just
happy living their life and just having
you know living their life in that
bubble and I you know I'm I'm not saying
this is a bad thing because I'm [__]
jealous of them at content right yeah
they content's the wrong word I mean
some of them are content some of them
are genuinely just like some of some of
them are genuinely just happy living the
lives that they have and that's
completely fine and I think to myself
huh there was a point in my life in my
childhood when I was that happy when I
didn't like when I was just happy with
the things I had there was a point in my
my lives where I you know this this is
the best kind of like uh allegory no
that's not the right word uh this is the
best analogy analogy that's that's what
I was looking for there was a point in
my lives when I was just happy [__]
eating chicken wings at McDonald's for
my mom every day of my life I did not I
did not crave Japanese food I did not
crave Japanese food I did not crave all
of these other kinds of like foods and
then you know suddenly I go out I try
nandos for the first time and I'm like
now I crave nandos yeah yeah yeah you
have like a you can like when you try
all these new things and explore you
almost then you're like okay but I I
need to keep satisfying all the things
that I've done yeah exactly right and I
never would have [__] eaten Thai food
yeah stayed in well or I would have had
it once be like oh wow look at this yeah
Oriental Cuisine ooh look at this ooh
and then I think to myself am I happier
now or was I happier back then being
ignorant of the larger world you know
and so like I guess my question
depressing isn't my question is would
you go back to that kind of ignorance
and just like blank like forget all your
memories [__] no and uh just I'd be on
the same path regardless I'd always find
a way to [__] myself over want more I
can't change the future I can't change I
am gone yeah if you could go back in
time and be like actually you just stay
in your little Welsh town I would maybe
I would maybe go back for like a week
but I wouldn't want to relive the whole
thing again yeah you know like just like
just purely based Nostalgia it would
bece to go back to that childish
mentality of the world is just like this
brand new thing and there's so much to
learn and there's so much you don't know
and like you know cuz I've always had
the the enjoyment of going out there and
learning something you being like oh wow
I never knew about this thing this is
cool I'm a dumb idiot I don't know
anything about anything but like would I
want to then relive my entire
adolescence again going through that
maybe not I'm pretty happy with how much
I have and the lack of knowledge I have
that I'm still yet to learn so yeah I do
it for a limited time do you think Luffy
wants to find one piece I don't even
know if he knows anything to be honest
like what do you think is going to
happen after he finds it you just like
K it's not what I was hoping
for what if it's all about knowing it's
out there in the journey to find it
rather than the actual ending of finding
it yourself you know becomes a dictator
[Music]
yeah he goes back to GARP and he's like
you're all right Granddad I I should
have joined the Marines you know now now
was whack now everything that Roger did
is uh he's going to become a
mar it makes so much more sense now that
you think about it yeah he's going to
inspire the next generation of pirates
by becoming a mar and then we get one
piece two two piece two piece two piece
yeah would you rather have STS exist in
real life or nen exist in real life n
nen you think so yeah I think cuz
there's more of a variety of nen and
there's so much more you can do with nen
than absolutely not there's no not more
variety of n yeah [__] stands are
like insane like stands are insane but n
is more moldable you know what I mean
like then you can kind of do whatever
your will is yeah stands you're Prett
obviously it's a skill issue that you
need to be borned with but so is St
so you know but I feel like stands get
so like eerily specific yeah also you
can't impress a non-stand user by having
a stand but you can impress a non- n
user with n g would be like my stand
ability is that every time the clock
strikes 11 I can suck back in the fart
if I have a fart and if I do it causes a
minor explosion somewhere in a fourth
world country Conor's ability would be
like every time I sit down for the
toilet even if it doesn't have a bedet I
can still summon the bedet my stand
wipes my ass for
my stand my [__] so it's clean my
stand is just ask GES it's
just yeah I I just think like with just
how the nen system is based I think
there's more of a variety and there's
more of a what's the word uh there's
more of a an opportunity to have like
way caller powers in nen than you can
withstand so although they are very
[__] similar this this question is
[__] weird V asks would you rather be
the main character in a monster themed
hentai or a character in isai where you
know you will die so basically have sex
with a monster or die I think I'd rather
die yeah I think I'd rather die too oh I
was going to say
monster well depend depends on the
monster range different I've seen
anime's definition of monster the
ugliest [__] orc alive kill me look
but if we're talking like you know daily
lives of monster
musir [__] off exactly exactly what what
kind of what kind of monsters are we
talking about talking for like humans
it's like the most grossest human beings
politicians uh you know you'd have sex
with them you like no I'm good I I'll
[Music]
die I will take death so what you're
asking is do you want to take a chance
in having the worst [__] experience
possible uh so it's basically like it
also really depends am I top or
bottom what does that depend what wait
wait wait what
what I think that's a I think that's a
valid question am I top or am I bottom
it's a monster uh it's probably top wait
tell tell me why it matters because if
I'm going to [__] a monster I'd rather
[__] a monster than be [__] by a
monster I'm just being real with Joel I
would rather [__] a monster in the butt
than get butt [__] by a monster is it
a real breaker kind of okay what if the
monster's a top are you you killing
yourself I'm killing myself oh
I I was just like the imagine the one
crer the one criteria between you and
[__] low tier guarding yourself is
like am I top or bottom I'm bottom all
right it's like if like morbius was like
you get the blue or the red pill like am
I top in the blue
yeah what I want to be top bro okay so
so it doesn't matter if you could like
be [__] the most hideous monster of
all time it's like some lovecraftian
monster that get if I do it from the
back I can't see his face you
know God can we put any of this in I
don't know all right the next ones we
are going to go through are some would
you rather questions that our producer
has put together uh so by the way big
thank you to you guys who got selected
on the patreon and uh if you want to be
involved in future videos and watch
extra patreon only content then again go
to patreon.com trashtaste Links in the
description come on come on do it but
let's go through some pre-selected
questions that our uh produc has got for
us so let's see what we got would you
rather always have Bo and not know it or
always smell Bo on everyone else oh this
just a theime convention experience
isn't it I don't mind the smell of Bo
much it depends on the
Bo Nasty ones but I generally don't mind
it I've smell some dank Bo before dep
how close I am like if I'm not that
close to you I don't really care if you
Bo no but if I'm like if I'm like this
and I get a proper W I'm like oh [__] no
have you not smelt some BO that is just
like rancid it literally smells like
trash okay actually there's one or two
times I can it's main like when someone
it's rare but there are some where it's
like God damn remember my first exp is
not that bad is minor most is is like
fine I'm fine with I'd rather not
subject other people to
me as someone with Dan Bo yeah yeah I
mean okay what if what if you have like
the worst Bo in the world and like you
you have like
the the stinkiest [__] Bo you can
imagine okay here's the question though
right if you selected the second option
of always small B on everyone else that
doesn't necessarily mean you also won't
have
Bo right well presumably you wouldn't
have Bo because the option is having Bo
yeah right but it didn't specifically
stay that so I needed to make
sure yeah I think I'd rather you'll
smell bi CU also you might be like
people won't want to hang out with you
if you stink I I tolerate other people I
don't mind you know what I mean I'm
chill I'm chill but you would be you
know you'd lose friends possibly I
always do small B on everyone else
anyway like in real life so I'd rather
just do that SM as well that's my
problem all right would uh would you
rather lose all your friends but keep
your BFF or lose your BFF and keep the
rest of your buds ooh so would you
rather have one and only one really
really good friend or never have a
really really good friend but just a lot
of like rather keep the BFFs medium
friends yeah yeah yeah I'd rather have
the BFF I think you only need a few very
very close friends in your life uh I
mean obviously having a lot of friends
is definitely an extra and is cool but
you know having that one just sometimes
having that one friend that will come to
you whenever you need or yeah whenever
you're in the time of need that's what
you need most in life yeah I think
that's an easy question yeah U this is a
good one would you rather walk in on
your parents or have them walk in on you
have you ever walked in [__] uh don't
think so I did when I was a kid oh yeah
it was
unfortunate why do you say it like it's
like a traumatic because it was a it is
it is every time every kid is if for any
kid it's a traumatic event if if if it
happened to me it would be a traumatic
event for me as well um so which one
would you rather I don't know both are
like equally traumatic the one is like
do you want to subject do you think your
parents would okay here's the thing
here's the thing okay why you got to
look on if you get walked in on would
you choose your mom or your dad if you
had if if oh to walk to walk in on in on
you oh Dad 100% my dad would be like
Yugo he'd stand over
me consume child imagine your dad
walking in on you like you'll be
stronger after this boy lock the [__]
door you
can if be like that that's weak cuz I
feel like okay here's here's the thing
if my dad walked in we would have the
acknowledgement to like never talk about
it okay I mean my dad's walked in on me
Jack most pick that Dad right so that's
an easy one but which one would you
rather you walk in on your parents or
your parents walking on you I think
which parent are we talking about that's
why I asked both both at the same both
of them at the same time coming in I
feel like if both walk in that's better
than just my mom walking in you my dad
would just your mom walks in
okay both if both my parents walked in
my mom would be like what the [__] and
my dad would be like let him
cook hold up my dad would make the
situation bearable hold up let him
come God my bum would be like so we we
need to like sit down and talk about
this so which one is it why you walking
on your parents or your parents walking
on you I think I'd rather have them
walking on me I think I'd rather have
them walking on me yeah because then it
feels like it's the natural circle of
life you know they're like cuz they
parents they understand you got you got
to do it if I walk then I'm like dude
youve already done it I'm already here
you pack it
up I feel like I I would be I would feel
less bad if they walked in on me than if
I walked in on them I think they'd feel
way more embarrassed than I would I
don't know I don't know what that is
about me but I think i' be like ah
whatever I think most people would take
getting walked in on by their parents
over walking in on their parents I know
think everyone I've talked to
uh if you have chill parents though you
have like really like annoying parents
so parents are like not good they' be
they'd like always bring it up or
something be would they I don't think
they would they might I don't know man
you have good parents my parents never
brought up what about getting walked on
by but it remains in my memory forever
what about getting walked in on by a
sibling I I'm asking this question cuz I
can't answer this question I think I
would rather have my parents walk in on
me to be honest would you rather have
your parents walk in on you or your si
but it's different right cuz he has
Brothers you brother and I have a sister
so if I had a brother I think be like
whatever about it but with the sister
that's just [__] awkward as [__] like
I wouldn't I would rather have with
Brothers it's like it's all about having
one up on each other your brother walks
in you he's kind of got one up on you
he's like I've seen it oh he can
blackmail you now yeah he's got no game
i s it you know what I mean Tiny
Dick I see the gentics didn't go to
you yeah where like the sister I imagine
you can be like I'm so sorry that was
really F like I don't even want to
imagine that yeah so yeah definitely
brother he he'd probably be like laau he
shout it like loser tell the whole
house would you rather be in history
books for something terrible or be
forgotten completely after you die I
think I'd rather be forgotten completely
after I die yeah I guess this is just do
you have an
ego it's it's the question of how famous
do you like how famous are you willing
to be I mean yeah I'd rather just
die terrible cuz then my family would
have to deal with it how terrible we
talking oh [__] how terrible are we
talking
yeah pretty [__] think of every terrible
person you've learned throughout [__]
history there's never been someone like
in a history textbook who's like I mean
what he did wasn't that bad you know
it's always something like what the hell
there is but I mean yeah but they're not
the ones that are remembered right the
ones that you remember the most are like
the really really all right but what if
you were just remembered for being like
Mega
cringe like not not even like
not even like doing something name me
someone in a history book that is Mega
CR this is just like asking would you
rather have a super cringe life or die
and no one else remember that you were
super cringe obviously I would just
rather not be cringe no I like cuz yeah
I do want I do want historians please
please tell me who is the biggest clown
in history right well I mean there's a
lot there's a lot of clowns but I don't
think the concept of cringe existed you
know Joey the the concept of cringe has
always exists we don't remember cringey
people we remember awful people and
heroic people we don't we we kind of
don't really I'm I'm now I'm just
wondering how far does the power of
cringe take you not generational it's
not cringe is not generational do you
think Henry VII was pretty cringe yeah
but he was more of a horrible person
which is what he remember yeah but no
one was like my Lord that was pretty
cringe okay okay but if but if people
would say if people could they would
definitely [__] say that are you
kidding me are you absolutely kidding me
my Lord that was an L my Lord this is
going in the cringe
collection this is going in the cringe
collection unfortunately if you called
him cringe uh you would have just gotten
[__] beheaded at the time but like if
you could I mean that's we look back on
it that's someone who would have been in
the history books he got beheaded for
calling the
cringe I think that's what some of his
wives did too actually that's the real
reason his wives died of cring like
Henry Henry you're you're like being a
bit cringe right now Henry I'm not going
to lie kill
them behead them for pointing out you
literally creating a new [__] state
of religion just uh so you can get
around divorce laws Henry that's a
that's that's pretty cap that's a little
cringe Henry that's cap Henry come on
now people are cringe yeah let's just go
through British history and oh oh like
who who is that person that gets
remembered for being like the biggest
like incest you know talk talking about
cringe like the biggest like genetically
incestral like baby that has ever been
born or something it's one of the Kings
right yeah it's one of the Kings right
is it isn't it like the Russian family
no am I crazy is it the Russian I
thought it was a British one was it I
thought it was who's the most anestrous
person alive we all have we all have
different kind why does g know this off
by heart given his
taste the most in there we go the cult
Clan oh I have seen a video on this oh
no this is going to a complete talking
is modern day this is modern day yeah I
I was thinking of like royal family yeah
where you see who's the most incestuous
royal family member of why are we
googling this what's wrong with us just
curious I'm just curious because I don't
know I don't know anything about
anything else about what these people
did aside from the fact
that King Charles of Spain well we were
all wrong rotting inside
jeez oh the habsburgs oh the hbur of the
11 marriages during the reign of the
Spanish hsbs only two were not incestous
God damn the history is super
interesting by the way I watch a bunch
of videos about it it's very and they're
also famous for the jaw yeah have you
seen the jaw go to go to type in the
Habsburg jaw you just go to Oh no just
click images you'll yeah just click
images and you'll
see
okay yeah like it's literally the first
thing that comes up oh it's this
right right right right God damn this I
you know this I this I feel I don't know
anything else about the history of this
aside from the fact that hey this is
this is pretty
cringe that's all that's what I was
trying to say you know is this where the
Giga Chad meme started no that's not
gigachad I'm like hey this is uh this is
uh incest pretty cringe right that is
pretty cringe that is pretty cringe is
Mark I don't know why Mark Zuckerberg's
there what the [__] wait does he have it
no no he doesn't so why is it there look
at that side profile on the second image
Jesus there's no way that's real godam
that's like a Tik Tok
filter you know you know the yo the
Habsburg jaw filter my favorite on Tik
Tok Jesus would you rather be able to
speak any language or be able to
communicate with animals animals yeah
hands down any language bro Google
Translate the Australian in me is seeing
animals animals would be [__] sick
you you You' you'd have a whole [__]
career immediately just because you can
speak to these [__] yeah totally I I
would charge 10 CR an hour for Rich Fox
who want to like impress their dog we're
like what's he saying he he's saying
you're pretty cring I'm like like he
loves you but what if you can understand
every animal and uh they're just like
[__] suffering or they say they hate
you like pass a dog this bark like help
help help help you're like everything I
know is a lie I thought they were just
permanently happy but they're not
because I'd be so rich from being the
animal Whisperer yeah I just go after to
that dog and be like get over that would
throw but no one would believe you no
one would believe you I we would do
tests to prove how would they test it uh
all right okay let's say wave activity
well we could be like you know there's
there maybe there's like a bunch of
different I'm sure there's ways we can
test the the only way you could test it
if if people could talk to animals
already you give me two seconds to
figure out a test here that's very
scientific all right there is definitely
a way you could prove that you can
understand what the animal's saying
there's got to be there has to be I
can't I can't think of a thing on the
spot yeah but there's got to be a way
cuz like think about how would you prove
that you can understand what animals say
where when like no one else understands
what an animal says you would simply set
some experiments that would require like
a feedback loop that would not require
any uh like anything like you could
prove that you understand what they're
saying and react to it by like giving
them X thing they ask for and that they
could react to it all the time
listen you probably wouldn't be a to get
to the point where everyone is 100% sure
but you can get to the point where
everyone's like why is this guy so good
at calming down all of these animals and
like figuring [__] out it's like the
trick is the trick is simple I go up to
the animal and go chill dog [__] chis
Pratt with the I would be there okay the
hash the the someone in the [__]
comments figure this out for me I don't
have I'm too lazy to do it [__] time
right now to figure this out but there's
got to be a way where you if you could
perfectly communicate with an animal and
understand it that you could easily
devise we've seen examples of like you
know certain animals that have like
shown really high intelligence right
like you know there's like there's like
that [__] uh elephant that like knows
how to paint [__] that's like saying
like I guess in a certain way if I can
speak Japanese to Joey or some foreign
language that only the both of us speak
how could I prove to you that I'm
speaking with Joey in
it yeah cuz like if I could I could
literally go up to a monkey and go spin
around three times yeah just him like
and he starts doing it like then you're
like speak but that's saying Conor you
don't speak [__] you could tell a dog
to like you know do a trick you bring me
your animal an animal I've never seen
before I'm like what's up what do you
want what's up I'm like hey you got to
help me out here they want me to yeah
but what if you told that animal to do
something that you would almost never
see that animal what I'm what I'm saying
what what you said is just like how
could you prove that you understand an
animal so it's like talking back to how
can I prove that I understand this
foreign language like we' we get input
right I'd be like if I was like what do
you want me to tell him to do I don't
know I mean if I didn't if I didn't
understand Japanese and obviously there
is no kind of like Baseline of [__] like
Japanese as a language I don't know how
I would prove that I would just have to
trust that I'm talking to BU monkeys
right and I'm like all right here's a
bunch of bananas monkeys eat them all
and then you're like all right now make
them stop eating guys stop eating the
bananas I don't know who they are and
they stop eating them you're like okay
well something's happening here we don't
know for sure but you can prove that
something's happening but you the same
with language you I can prove that like
I I know this language but I you don't
know 100% if you get that animal to do
like not not just like one movement but
like get them to do like a sequence of
movements that they would almost never
exhibit naturally you be able to
communicate you could tell them to do it
like if you do these like arbitary task
I will give you a [__] OB they're still
the same intelligence so you'd have to
work around that and that would be the
tricky part because if I was talking to
a human we can start devising devising
like really complicated solutions to
proving 100% but we would work with
whatever the animal has and I'd be like
okay what's the the animal I can
communicate the most and is most able to
follow or communicate with me and I can
be like hey I can promise to give you
all the stuff and we can work out what
you want and I can help you out here but
you got to help me out yeah so you could
devise something haven't they tried
teaching animals language yeah language
the problem is they don't speak language
yeah I know but like a form of like
communication yeah yeah like they
they've already taught a gorilla sign
language or something like so yeah I'm
sure there's an animal that could be
able to communicate one way with you
where you could find a way to figure it
out cuz all you need is one of you to
understand what the other saying to
start figuring something out here yeah
the only caveat in this choice would be
that you would also probably hear a lot
of uh intrusive thoughts of animals as
well because they don't have a filter
the reason why I went on to this my was
like you can't [__] prove this cuz I
would be the number one animal [__]
expert on Earth I I be a to talk [__]
expert I might poor choice of wearing
that I might I might fall in love with
animal Joey what's wrong with the animal
he wants to f i can you know I might be
in love with them cuz I can communicate
with them well yeah like like like okay
point being I would build a massive
[__] complex with my money that I've
gathered from charging billionaires to
talk to their animals that I would have
a [__] complex where there's no
goddamn animals allowed in there so I
can get out of these get away from these
[__] you think you could build an
army if you can communicate with animals
100% oh dude are you kidding me oh all
you have to do is go up to a bunch of
monkeys and go do you know Planet of the
Apes and then they'll be like no what's
that and then you'd be like it goes like
this how far do you think you can get
with an army of animals versus the world
if you just wanted to take a take over
the world you end the world you could I
mean there's a lot more animals than
humans there is a lot but humans are
smarter we have tools can I control
every animal yeah yeah you're donezo bro
bugs would ruin everything if you could
actually organize bugs to start [__]
[__] up if you organize a swarm of ants
ants are so do you know how many ants
there are you be
done like a tile it' be game over bro it
would AR waves i g if I started sending
a hord of centipedes into your house
you'd kill
yourself that's the like that's the
immune in Australia like no centipedes
are disgusting that's just Sunday
bro Australia Australia is like the last
Bastion that dum we be Australia would
be the final front here speak any
language or be Australian is the
question all right thank for watching
this episode of trash taste those are
our would you rathers let us know down
below if youly disagree with any of
these and make sure to get involved with
these by going to our patreon we fully
reamped it again and we have a bunch of
content on that is exclusive there now
fun little 30 minute episodes of us
doing little dumb stuff maybe playing
games and you know what just for you
guys we'll show a quick five to 10
second clip of this week's episode r m I
love all these shows is Rony kin a show
that you have to grow up with question
no no really you think it you think it
still holds up I think definitely yeah I
I I feel like I just don't I the only
caveat is that
was like hell yeah so thank you so much
and please do consider it because
scaring allow us to do some more cool
stuff look at all these patrons though
aren't they amazing sex thank you by the
way to all the patrons who did send us
who would you rathers um and if you want
to participate in future videos like
this then make sure to go on to the
patreon by go to patreon.com trashtaste
also follow us on Twitter send us memes
on the subreddit and if you had our face
listen to us on Spotify and we will see
you guys next week bye bye
[Music]
bye